do you have a name for your fan base
Gators the Gators yeah the Gators uhuh
uh wow are they
toxic cuz I'm not toxic though no I'm
just saying some of these fan bases get
a little aggressive I've had little kid
folks come at me they're pretty crazy I
I'm not going front though they might go
crazy on you if you like the Gators yeah
if you don't if you don't if you growl
at me they going to growl back what does
that mean oh like like H yeah the death
Gat the death row cuz yeah the death row
what you mean why I Gat is because my my
skin is bulletproof so I'm big Gator it
just came about I did a freestyle on a
platform shout out to I95 I did a
freestyle shout out to those guys bars
on I95 I was like 2020 I ain't giving
out no favors my skin bulletproof [__]
I'm big Gator and then my fans would
just take it and be like big Gator big
Gator big gator but before I tapped into
it I'm like can I really relate to this
name regardless of the skin being
bulletproof and I can because they very
patient and they they are warm-hearted
but cold blooded have you had fans show
up to your shows wearing Florida Gator
merch like gear no like atbo Jersey like
look Gators you no I don't I don't think
so I don't think so I don't think I ever
caught that before you got to go to
Gainesville now I do Gainesville Florida
is where the florid show me mad love
though like I have a good fan base in
Florida though where where in Florida
have you performed um
Orlando uh
Miami Miami's nice somewhere else have
you been to the strip clubs in Miami yet
booby trap booby traps a movie it's also
un it's almost unable booby trap is a
real thing when you're in booby trap
you're really trapped and you can't
leave and I don't like to party but when
you don't want to leave the Ubers are
taking forever to get there there's a
line outside it's [__] 7:00 in the
morning I'm tired miserable Miser you be
what I mean after pulling an all nighter
and I'm on [__] jet lag from the west
coast and then you're with this guy DJ
AO he's a psychopath good guy though I'm
sure you've met him he's I had a time in
my life at booby trap I couldn't believe
I a't want to leave my team kept saying
you ready to go you spend a lot money oh
no I didn't no I didn't no I don't do
those type of things did you eat did I
they got they got food at booby trap I'm
I don't remember they got some of the
best strip club food in the country is
in Florida Miami specifically G5 has
great wings um uncle trick uh made sure
he fed me when I came out there his food
was really Trick Daddy fed you what did
he cook cuz you know he C I mean he got
he got a he got a spot I didn't know
that yeah he got a restaurant was it
good it's called Uh Sunday's with um
Sunday eater Sunday I just remember I
think he was on Cribs or some show
cooking some wild [__] you remember that
yeah he
shout trick Florida like pancake thing
he was cooking no I had some turkey
wings turkey wings did I was it yeah I
had some turkey wings uh are those
bigger than chicken wings it was fire
I've had a turkey leg I've never had a
turkey wing at like a restaurant turkey
no I mean that's why you got that
restaurant because I got to go I've only
been to like a finger lick which in my
household turkey wings was a thing but
not for me I didn't like turkey wings
until I got older you got to go to
tootsies and get the fried lobster tail
while a lady massages you they have uh
they have non strippers there what type
of freaky dead no no no it's tootsies
tootsies is a legendary strip club you
know Drake said I'm toot shoulder rubs
I've never I've never been there so
tootsies they have dancers and then they
have literal fully clothed lady like
masseuses so like some someone's aunties
is in there like they'll rub your back
for like 45 minutes for or 45 bucks I
think is for 30 minutes or something
like that or it's 45 bucks for 15
minutes and it's amazing so you're just
sitting there eating maybe the fight's
on maybe the Dolphins are playing and
then you got a lady giving you a real
massage like a real massage it's not
like no weirdo [__] like it's a real
masseuse oh really survive yeah oh I got
to go it's it's not a bad place I got to
go but booby trap is a movie for sure
yeah booby trap is a trap for sure you
know what I noticed when you go to the
Shri Club in New York it's more about
the bartenders than it is the
dancers is that fair oh that's a New
York thing yeah that's a New York thing
right like bartenders might get more
love than strippers for sure yeah mhm